الحب التي لا تعرف استراحه لا ليلى ولا
نهارا لفي السماء ولا على اليابسه والبحر
دمى الرعب خلال القصف الروسي بصواريخ
ومسيرات على ميناء اسماعيل المطل على نهر
الدانوب باوديسا ساعتين من هنا كانت تصدر
الحبوب الى الخارج بعد انسحاب موسكو من
اتفاق تعذرت تمديده اذ وصلت المفاوضات الى
طريق مسدود اعتراض القوات الاوكرانيه
لمعظم المسيرات المشاركه في الهجوم وفق
روايتها لم يمنع تفاديا الحاق اضرار كبيره
بالميناء والمستودعات وحجز التفتيش لم
يتاخر ردوا كييف التي قصفت محطه كهرباء
فرعيه في منطقه كورسك الروسيه تحدث حاكم
المنطقه الحدوديه عن انقطاع الكهرباء عن
سبع بلدات جراء الهجوم من جهته اعلن
الحاكم الروسي لمدينه سيفا ستوبول احباط
هجوم صاروخي قرب مطار
حرب المسيرات المتبادله بين المتقاتلين في
الصراع تقابلها شبهه مشتعله يزعم كل طرف
انه يحقق تقدما فيها تراهن وتتفاءل كياف
بترشيح الكفه لصالحها بعد وصوله اول دفعه
من دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه التي طال
انتظارها والموعود رسميا منذ يناير الماضي
لم يفوت الرئيس فلودي مرسيليسكي الفرصه
ليلقي كلمه ترحيبا بالدبابات التي بحث
صوته وهو يطالب بها مع منظومه صواريخ
اتاكمز لا تفرح كثيرا رد عليه اكثر من
مسؤول روسي بعد هذا الخطاب توعد المتحدث
باسم الكرملين
انه لا يوجد علاج سحري ولا سلاح يمكنه
تغيير ميزان القوه في ساحه المعركه
تعادت واشنطن بتزويد اكياس باحدى وثلاثين
مزوده بذخائره تحتوي على اليورانيوم
المنظم بعيار 120 ملم ذخيره مثيره للجدل
بسبب مخاطرها السامه على الجيش والمدنيين
بنبره حاده انتقد مجددا نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي
تدفق السلاح الغربي الثقيل على اوكرانيا
هدد بان الخيارات امام روسيا
تتضاءلوا ومنها خيار المواجهه المباشره مع
النيتو الذي تحول الى كتله فاشيه شبيهه
بمحور هتلر على حد تعبيره نتائج محاور
المعارك المباشره او غير المباشره في هذا
الصراع اما غير ثابته او غير واضحه في حرب
الكل يخرج فيها ما بقي من اوراق وسلاح
وعتاد بحثا عن حسم مفقود ولا يبدو قريبا
تكلفه الحرب الانسانيه قبل الماديه على
الجميع باهظه ومؤلمه
وبخسائر قد تستمر عقودا طوال